what's the what's the schedule today
DeSean what do you have going on rest of
the day so there's a lunch of the legend
she's coming up here shortly spend some
time with some of the legends around
time today and then from there it's just
kind of bouncing around a little bit
with a couple interviews and we'll get
rolling around four o'clock in dress and
get ready for the red carpet head on
over to Phil or over to the draft how
you feeling so good do you know this is
them this has been an awesome process
this is obviously an honor to even be
invited to to Philly for the draft and
my family's enjoying it they're having a
good time and I'm just kind of taking it
all in day by day but what kind of
advice have you gotten since you're not
projected to go high in the first round
and if you do go it may be late in the
first run you're going to be sitting in
the green room for a little while the
advice I've gotten is just once again
just enjoy the moment I mean there's
this experience in itself is something
that's absolutely amazing and as soon as
you make it bigger than what it is and
you know start looking two things that
can happen down the road and like a lot
of negatives you're not going to enjoy
the time that you're having so we're
just trying to stay in the moment as
much as we can how would you sum up your
season this last season at Notre Dame
for someone you didn't see you play how
would you describe it you need I ended
up for Nate you know seven of those
eight games we have an opportunity to
fourth quarter win in it so it was
definitely a situation in which we were
a little disappointed and we liked to
win those games the fourth quarter and
we did the year before but you know as a
quarterback of a team of those four and
I was pretty disappointed frustrated
throughout most losses how you and coach
Kelly okay he had some comments about
you that you should still be in college
you guys had a conversation absolutely
you know Chris Kelly and I have a really
good relationship and he let me know
that when I decided to leave you know
there definitely is a lot of room for
improvement and you know embrace those
comments and I took it for exactly what
they are and I just plan on making as a
present at the next level
this decision has a lot to do about my
personal development where I think I
stand you know with my game
name and quite frankly I thought you
know microbes really won a Super Bowl
one day and there's one time I guess I
explained this to me though the the
quote where you had Tom Brady's mind Cam
Newton's body can you can you give me
the context of that DeSean yeah so I
mean the the the conversation that was
had was about you know where I set my
goals and and how I can take the the
responsibilities from the Notre Dame
offense and and let that lead into a
situation in which I could be successful
in the NFL so when talking about Tom
Brady's mind it's like hey look you know
with all the responsibilities I had at
Notre Dame I'll be able to you know
transfer that over and hopefully prepare
and has an electric temporary has an
understand defenses and offenses where
Tom perdy does and if you can add that
with another system of one of the best
athletes and the you know probably in
all sports that was Cam Newton that's
the ultimate goal except you if I the
way the quote came out was I am no
Tommy's brain I am can do his body now
it's not close to that and I'm glad that
people laughed at that because that is
absolutely hilarious I know there's a
lot working to get there and I'm just
setting my goals high so I can hopefully
you know achieve the greatness I want to
treat but I that's why I wanted to ask
you because when it came out I went wait
a minute is he saying that he has Tom
Brady and mine and Cam Newton's body
they're gonna they're gonna rough you up
about that absolutely go look at any
picture of me everyone knows I don't
have cam name's Bob and Tom Brady's won
five super water thank you to Penn you
know a little better than for Nate in
his last year's last couple years I said
that was imagine if I could go ahead and
take someone like Tim Tom Brady's mind I
put it with campaigns body
there's my goal if you wanna see where
my goals are and where I want to be
worth it it's it's five plus Super Bowls
it's one of the more athletic guys in
the league and it's guy who's more
prepared and you know more determined
anyone else out there favorite team
growing up Philadelphia Eagles right
here in Philly that that was the extent
of Randall Cunningham so I was following
this like dad was favorite quarter also
favorite quarterback was obviously
Randall Cunningham as well well no
actually mine was Donovan McNabb
have you met Donovan I'm not I'm not
I've always wanted to my
he's there today I'm sure I'm gonna swim
around that I'm looking around as much
as I can but but you do you play more
like Donovan McNabb than you do Randall
Cunningham uh-huh uh-huh well I guess
we'll see when I get to the league what
my left eye looks like when I get there
do you have any idea where you're going
no idea no idea and it's not as much fun
right to say that because that's gotta
be strange you go to Philadelphia you're
going to sit there for a couple hours
tonight and then you're going to wait
and then you're going to go okay now my
next four or five years is going to be
in this city yeah yeah I mean it's the
beauty of crap man are you hug and give
me the game plan with the Commissioner
when you go up on stage hug handshake
bro hug combo what are we gon um
whatever he does and allowed to be
Natura because as soon as you plan to do
one thing and he plans you're just
looking awkward in front of everyone
maybe just go a firm handshake just oh
you're there it's all business to show
absolutely I'm done for that you're fan
of parents going a family going to be
there yeah yeah families in town they're
all enjoying this process with me and
Tostitos calm for all your NFL Draft and
Cinco de Mayo recipe needs so you're
already a pro you're getting paid hey
have fun tonight and thanks for joining
us of course thank you all right there
Shawn Kaiser joining us former Notre
Dame quarterback the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience